Emily:
Is that you?
He-hey!
Hey.
Hey, I'm really happy you're
here.
Emily:
Why is that?
Because I like you...a lot.
You wanna go for a walk?
♪♪
Tom Holland:
You meet Cherry,
and he's a kid who's having a
hard time.
He just doesn't really know why
he feels the way he feels.
And he meets this wonderful
lady called Emily.
Cherry is the first time Emily
has ever experienced love.
It's just pheromones playing
tricks on people.
I love you.
Ciara Bravo:
She's finally escaped an abusive
home.
Ciara Bravo:
It forces her to face her
demons.
In a way that causes her to
self-destruct.
♪♪
Emily:
I'm leaving for good at
the end of the semester.
Please tell me that you're
kidding.
This isn't funny.
Emily:
Why would I be kidding you?
♪♪
(Door slams)
(Road noise)
Recruiter:
She broke your heart?
(Bang)
I like him.
♪♪
Platoon in unison:
Yes, Drill Sergeant!
♪♪
She is the one that leaves him
and he goes into this spiral.
Tom Holland:
And he joins the military.
♪♪
(Glass shatters)
(Crowd cheering)
Tom Holland:
When they come back together,
they don't come back together
for the right reasons.
Ciara Bravo:
When he comes back from Iraq,
♪♪
Tom and I completely destroy our
character's lives.
(Ticking)
(Gunshots)
Get on the ground!
♪♪
Tom Holland:
He doesn't really know what
to do without her.
And he doesn't really know how
to live life with her.
♪♪
We don't shy away from the
negative aspects of this type of
love.
♪♪